foreign
let's go to Maggie in Columbia South
Carolina what's up Maggie
hi Dr John thanks for having me of
course thank you I'll be in Columbia
South Carolina in a few weeks
oh awesome yeah it's a great City my
husband and I are Avid listeners of your
show and we appreciate all you do well
I'm really grateful for you thank you so
much what's up how can I help
so my question is how do I begin
asserting myself in my marriage when
I've been dismissive of myself and my
needs for most of my life and I can
provide background yeah of course tell
me more
okay so my parents divorced when I was
young my dad chose to leave his role in
my life I had turned a disorder to
eating and spent High School hiding and
eating disorder
um moving away to college my disordered
eating became crippling and I turned to
sex to satisfy my loneliness
which led to a lot of unwanted sexual
trauma I didn't have any hope and had
considered taking my life until I met my
husband now but he was my boyfriend at
the time and so fast forward 10 years
with extensive therapy my husband and I
now have two young kids and I've had
postpartum depression with both
foreign
so I'm at a point right now in my
marriage where I no longer want to take
a back seat I want to be an equal and
have my needs heard and my boundaries
acknowledged it's just been hard for me
because
with my whole background I'm so used to
just putting everyone else before myself
and I've spent a lot of time being
lonely yeah
you articulated that really really well
um how often have you said those things
out loud in a row like that
so this is this is not a story that
you've told over and over again this is
a story that you are beginning to feel
strong enough to begin to put out into
the universe is that fair
that's fair okay who when you were a
little kid where did where did you learn
that your job was to take care of
everybody else
um what gave you that lack of control in
your world that that was the way you
started trying to grab onto it
had just decided
to participate anymore
um what do they do what do they do to
your mom
um crushed her yeah
yeah we my sister and I absorbed that
tell me about that
um
so my mom got remarried pretty quick
after my parents split but she remarried
someone somewhere to my dad and she was
always the person taking care of my dad
or my stepdad so we had just kind of
learned like okay we take care of other
people and I grew up in a really passive
aggressive home
um so it was kind of like you have these
but you don't talk about them but then
you let them out in kind of above our
way
yeah passive aggressive homes are like
mind reader homes and they make people
crazy yeah yeah
um which is why an eating disorder was
so great because I could control
everything well you can yeah yes yes and
so you say you hit it
um yeah
uh tell me about that
yeah so I kind of had heard
um
so I'll just to give Clarity so I had
for probably I'm in recovery now but had
started with anorexia which was not easy
to hide because you start losing a lot
of weight and then moved into being
bulimic for a long time which was easier
to hide because you tend to remain the
same weight
um
so that was kind of easier to hide I was
actually very high achieving in
academics and did really well so I would
kind of come and go for my house as I
needed and that's not uncommon because
that was another way you got people off
your back
absolutely I'm gonna I'm gonna make all
I'm gonna check all of the boxes that
you need to leave me alone
yes
and because I want to paint a picture
for you how this dance works okay
there is a
we always talk about the divorce like
dad walks out on us
but from a trauma perspective especially
for young kids we often forget the two
or three or four years before that
that Mom and Dad's relationship would
have been a mess
and that chaos would have ricocheted
through all the little kids in the house
through every all the relational
interactions in the house so at a really
young age
you start feeling how electric
everything is and how you don't want to
make mom mad because she was just crying
because like there's not just a divorce
is rarely just instantaneous right and
so then that happens
and you're a little girl wondering what
was so bad about you the dad left and
then Mom rushes to fill that Gap with
some knucklehead some other guy and
you're still you're still wondering
where's mom what about us are we not
good enough right you see him so the
whole dance happens but then a weird
thing happens
you find safety when you're alone
and your body craves it and so you start
grabbing ways to control and you end up
realizing you you found some currency
with your body I can actually connect
with people and keep them at arm's
length at the same time by by Sleeping
with people that I'm not super invested
with
you see how you're trying how your body
plays both sides of that equation until
it falls in on itself
yes it actually it actually works for a
while right just like alcohol Just Like
Cocaine like it all works for a while
um what would tell me what was about
this guy you were dating amidst all of
this that suddenly you said he's
different
yeah so he um like I said he's my
husband now we actually listen to your
show together
um he it was interesting right he just
wasn't selfish he was just more
interested about me as a person and
trying to meet my needs and just kind of
taking whatever he could get
and that was probably the first time
anyone's really done that for me
um and nothing about your past and I'm
going to start talking sexually but I'm
talking about your past just the
challenges you've had that didn't scare
him off
foreign
I
got to kind of pretend to be someone new
for a while
um eventually that had come out
um and we were able to work through that
okay
so he didn't leave and that was kind of
another thing it was like oh I'm just
sharing more and more about myself
um that I think is just going to cause
you to leave like other people have okay
and you're still here so fast forward to
right now what is it about this season
or what needs are not being met are you
not vocalizing or are you not feeling
like you're an equal part of your home
I
so
we have I know I mentioned we have two
young kids and having postpartum
depression with both the first time I
went through it I felt very lonely and
it kind of took me back to this place of
like
um
I guess it kind of just took me back
um you know I felt like I was
but I know my husband's not here to
defend himself but you know Hey listen
I've had two kids and I did not do it
well either time so okay okay yeah there
was a lot of game that came with
postpartum depression with my son he's
my oldest now and it was just you know
um you know why don't you want him and
why are you so sad and this is what
you've always wanted
um and so it just became one of those
things where I started hiding again
right
I'm so sorry um you know then we have my
son and he grows up and well he's not
grown he's the one okay but we
um you know kind of go back and forth
with trying to raise him and then I got
pregnant with my daughter and so now all
of these fears of abandonments are
coming back and like I'm not enough
um each time there's been a huge life
event like getting married having my son
and then having my daughter it feels
like everything from my past bubbles
back up right and and I want you to
maybe the first time in your life stop
stop the civil war between you and your
body
it's it's trying to take care of you the
best it can
and it knows this story
where kid number two comes in Dead
Leaves
so it it knows that story and so it's
just trying to remind to get your
attention to remind you as loud as
possible hey this is what's coming even
though it's not right
when mom probably heard
um or stepdad heard a full narrative
about what you were experiencing in
middle school they probably told you
that it was dumb or stop talking or you
should just leave or we're tired stop go
go go go we're in the middle of
something
and so you learned at a young age that
stories about you
turn people away from you
and so over time your body really went
to war with you and you started telling
somebody that you had a vested interest
in about you the truth about you some of
the experiences that you you've had
and so all along the way your body's
trying to be a friend in this deal and
trying to help you out
it's just now that those things that
used to keep you alive and keep you safe
are now
making him making you crazy and there's
nothing like having a kid like feeling
like having your and again nobody needs
another six foot two white male telling
women how their bodies work right but
like there's
nothing to make you feel less Con in
control than having a baby right your
body's not yours anymore
it's like it's like a an RV for a a kid
and yeah yep it kind of does its own
things and it grows and it's weird and
it stretches and it's not yours knowing
your kid's born you're a jungle gym and
a food dispenser and like and then a
couple of months in husband comes pawing
back at you like hey and all of a sudden
whoosh your body remembers when we
didn't have control
remember when we kept everyone at arm's
length so that we could protect
ourselves and we did protect ourselves
but we went crazy because we were
isolated alone
and you see that weird figure eight
dance it just happens over and over and
over again
yes
so you are not gonna like my answer on
where to go from here
you won't
um
you are going this is not a to be fully
present to start speaking your needs out
loud to say things that you want to to
be heard in your home from your kids
from yourself from your husband from
your community
there's not a checklist that you can do
by yourself
what you're going to have to do is
practice relational safety which means
you're going to have to regularly get
with people
who are not your husband and practice
saying things out loud and then feeling
your body when it feels completely and
totally exposed
and heading into that storm not away
from it like you've done for your entire
life
okay you cannot and hear me say this and
I'm saying it because I love you you
cannot do this part by yourself
here's why the pressure your body will
feel
your your autonomic nervous system won't
allow it the pressure your body will
exert on you to not fully Express how
you feel to your husband because he
might leave that story is so woven into
the fabric of your body
that you're going to always hedge your
bets and then you're going to hate
yourself for hedging your bets and then
your body's got a whole system of
behaviors to take care of you when you
hate yourself like disordered eating
like
finding yourself by sleeping around like
whatever behaviors and then you're just
gonna invent new ones you know what I
mean like working 90 hours a week or
um
see there you go
and most of us we don't realize it we
just go through our lives
going from anxiety to OCD to Addiction
in this Loop and we just pass we just
finally kick addictions and kick
addictions until we find one that the
world rewards us for and usually that's
codependency on a relationship or
working a lot
and eventually the work will go to
alcohol almost or you're going to find
somebody at work that's going to make
you feel alive again because you're so
distant and you're going to end up
doing something that you can't take back
relationally with your husband
is that fair
so I will tell you one thing you can do
by yourself well so let me back up
um
everything you've been told about your
body
up until now that
um
it's for somebody else's enjoyment
you're not in control all those things
has led you to this story that your body
can't be trusted
and think about this for a second this
is hard when I'm gonna say out loud okay
is that cool
yes
yes you your body told you you can't
even be happy with your kids
yeah
your body told you you can't even tell
when you look good and when you don't
your body told you we have one value
and that is getting that guy off
or finding connection with fill in the
way so your body has been trying to take
care of you for so long and you've got
to make peace with the fact that your
body's not telling you the truth anymore
and that's a scary realization and also
a super freeing realization
I'm nodding
okay so we're gonna get some friends
whether that's a group whether that's a
woman's group whether that's a counselor
um it may be time for a new therapist I
would recommend a group because you are
probably
um just by talking to you you are
brilliant enough to work work your way
and I've I've just spent my whole career
working with especially young women with
eating disorders uh disorder eating and
they are Masters at controlling a
conversation
right
yep some of the best I've ever
encountered ever and I was a dean of
students at a law school for five years
so it's they can't hold that candle so
um I recommend getting in with a group
or getting three or four women that are
your friends and tell them that some
idiot on a podcast or on YouTube told
you that you've got to have three or
four people in your life that know
everything all the things
okay and I know that sounds terrifying
and insane
this will only be healed relationally
once your body begins to learn that it's
okay to say things out loud then you can
enter into that space with your husband
that says I need help around here or I
know you love me and when you ask me
why I can't be happy with our kids
my body leaves I'm out
and right now saying those words out
loud are terrifying right
yeah
here's this here's one thing you can do
by yourself okay I want it's remember
those little t-shirts I don't know how
old you are but there used to be
t-shirts called mind the gap and
I always thought it was making fun of
the store
um is that what it was for Kelly what
was it for Kelly no they're for it's
British when you get on the um
the underground oh behind the Gap
because they when you get on the
Underground they tell you that so don't
step in the in between the the platform
and the the car I always thought mind
the gap was making fun of the store that
was telling you what to wear and whatnot
I guess I missed that so I'm going to
tell you to mine the Gap and here's what
I mean by that
I want you to begin to look for and
probably get a journal and write it down
or use the notes app on your phone I
want you to start looking for places
in moments in your day
when your body starts to run off on you
and just get some space between it taken
off on you and what just happened
so your husband walks in the door and
all of a sudden you start to feel the
need to leave the room
pause right there before you leave and
just ask yourself
what are you trying to protect me from
and it's really a curiosity it's not a
it's not we're not mad I'm not angry I'm
just asking my bike what did you find
here that was scary
or when your kid comes in and you start
to push them away
ask yourself
what is it about my baby that I'm trying
to push away right now is it am I
overstimulated is his breath really
weird has he not changed his diaper and
actually I need help from Dad and I
haven't said it out loud and he's too
clueless to even pay attention like what
is it that is causing my hand to rise up
and push my baby away
and again it's a curious thing it's not
that you're a bad mom because you're
clearly not it's just your body's got
some wired some stuff wired into it and
we're just going to get to the bottom of
what it's trying to protect you from
my guess is it's going to try to protect
you from people that you love getting
too close because if they find out about
you they're going to leave again
okay so mind the gap begin to practice
that space I still have to do that all
the time too that's a practice I think
most of us will in go do the rest for
the rest of our lives
um
but before the day's over I want you to
find a group
find some some friends some women that
you will make a regular connection with
on a calendar you won't miss and you are
going to practice saying things out loud
and feeling completely and totally
exposed
without the pressure of your body
thinking your husband's going to leave
when he finds out
or that your kids are going to fill in
the blank whatever they're gonna they're
gonna take off on you
hang on the line here's I'm gonna do I'm
gonna send you
um own your past change your future the
book I want you to read through it in
fact I'm gonna send you two copies I
want you to read one and your husband to
read one also I'm gonna send you both of
the questions for humans couples cards
here's what I want you to do with those
just practice having a conversation with
your husband and these are no pressure
there's no they're just slow like uh
it's not bass fishing where you're
pulling a lure back all the time this is
catfish and you're still out there
letting it sit these are low impact
questions you'll go to dinner do five
cards 10 cards and you're just getting
two quote unquote know each other a
little bit better but the whole time
what you're really doing is practicing
telling your husband things about you
catching your body when it starts to
take off
and reminding yourself that you're safe
you're safe you're safe I'm so grateful
for you Maggie so grateful for you